does everyone make $250,000 a week by
the end yeah everyone made the same
isn't it weird when you have a cast and
there's you know five of you who want to
go in together and there's like one hold
out who says you know you guys I
think I can do better on my own it it
could break up an ensemble test right
yeah yeah why do you laugh because that
happened didn't it uh no not exactly
that way but I certainly I was more in
the latter Camp than the former Camp so
the was
you I wasn't an I just felt like
we all had individual careers that we
had nurtured up into that point and so
when you end up with an agent and a
manager and an attorney that you've like
you have relationships with them and
they're hardcore fighting for you
financially for your future right you
know you're fighting for yourself and
your take within it so it wasn't like I
was trying to take someone else's money
I just wanted my team to fight as hard
as they could for me for my next
season's work